hey francis do you want to keep your
online activity
private yes i don't want anyone to know
i secretly watch bbc comedy
embarrassing that's why you need surf
shark vpn
how can shark surf shut up surfshark is
a virtual private network
available as an easy to use app and
browser extension that lets you place
your laptop
or phone anywhere in the world allowing
you to access the internet as if you
were in another country
this means that i can access a whole
host of websites
that i wouldn't be able to access in the
uk not only that
you can protect your online identity by
masking your true ip address
with surfshark you can protect yourself
from data theft
tracking surveillance and commercial
targeting and it's great value for money
because
one serv shark account can be used on
multiple devices
so you can access problematic content
wherever you are and by problematic
content we do mean trigonometry click
the link below
and use our code trigonometry to get
83 percent off plus three extra months
for free
surf shark also offers a 30-day
money-back guarantee
so there's no risk to trying it out for
yourself click the link below
and use our code trigonometry to get
83 percent off plus three extra months
for free
do you think that western governments in
particular overreacted to the pandemic
well they first under reacted and then
overreacted i think that would be the
right way to put it but there was a way
to get this
right that averted mass death
and also averted lockdowns
[Music]
hello and welcome to trigonometry i'm
francis foster i'm constantine kissin
and this is a show for you if you want
honest conversations
with fascinating people does not get any
more fascinating than the guest we have
for you today he's an accomplished
historian and prolific author
neil ferguson welcome to trigonometry
it's great to be here but of course you
had my much more interesting wife the
other day so i'm you know
i i know when to bask in reflected glory
well we had we had the better half now
we've gone for the other half so we've
got you as well
thank you very much it's more like a
third actually it's good to have the
other third on the show
neil uh of course you you're very
gracious to your
brilliant wife but you are as i said a
very interesting man
a very accomplished author your latest
book is called doom the politics of
catastrophe
we've had a couple of those in the last
year i feel uh
you know what made you want to write the
book well i'd been thinking of writing
something about the history of disaster
and dystopia before covert 19 came along
and i was trying to persuade my
my publisher that i i could write a book
that would use
science fiction as well as as history to
to describe our strange relationship
with disaster
and he was kind of giving me funny looks
and and then a disaster happened
and i think i was quite quick to see
back in january last year that this was
going to be a big pandemic
and i thought well this is surely the
way to frame
the book if we can if we can locate this
disaster in a broader historical
perspective
comparing with all the disasters in
history that will help
readers understand what they are going
through
so that was the reason for writing and
publishing before the disaster is over
clearly
covert 19 is not over but i felt like a
lot of people were just
disorientated and there was a tendency
in the media
last year particularly to think that
this was going to be
comparable in its scale to the great
influenza pandemic of 1918-19 or even to
the black death some people
mentioned that but it was it was obvious
a year ago that it wasn't going to be
that bad it was going to be bad but not
really really bad
so there's a need i think to put these
kinds of event
in historical perspective that's really
what the book tries to do
and the the opening sentence to your
entire book i found so powerful neil
and i'm going to paraphrase it and
butcher it and i apologize in advance
but the
sentence was something along the lines
of we've never been
more fearful of the future whilst
knowing so little about the past
why did you write that sentence and why
did you open your book with it
well i think there is a great sense of
of fearfulness and uncertainty in our
world today
and uh often that leads to great
overreactions
uh and extreme responses to
to challenges that previous generations
would not have been
so thrown by and part of the reason i
think for that
is that we are historically
extraordinarily ignorant
now of course you could say we've always
been historically ignorant nobody
studies history but i do think something
has happened to our relationship to
history
and it's particularly obvious when you
look at young people
because of the way history is taught and
history has been
decoupled from uh traditional ideas of
what we should learn about the past
and increasingly it embraces a sort of
activist agenda
so people are not in fact taught to
think about the past as anything other
than
a series of terrible lapses from
political correctness which we should
all disapprove of
this is not a great way of thinking
about about human history
uh just going back in time and going to
terrible terrible races
i mean that's not how you should think
about the human past but it's how i'm
afraid more
our kids and indeed now young adults are
taught
so the idea i had was let's try to
locate what's happening
in a proper historical perspective not
condescending
to past generations and when you do that
you realize that it's not the end of the
world
now the media especially the internet
proven media
have tremendous incentive to represent
every crisis as the end of the world
so not only is covert 19 the black death
but
if a bunch of lunatics storm the us
capital on january the 6th
it's the civil war uh and this kind of
inflation
uh of historical significance is is what
i'm trying to push
back against because it allows a kind of
hysteria to build about
each breaking news event which is
clearly not helpful to
to rational responses by voters and by
politicians
it's an interesting point you make neil
particularly about the media because
this is something i've been thinking
about quite a lot
we have research here in the uk which
shows that
uh when polled uh british people on
average think that about 10
of the public have been killed by covert
19 which would make about
6 million people the actual figure is
0.1
and in america there's been some polling
across different media platforms of cnn
and msnbc i think people who regularly
watch those
uh think that you're 50 percent 50
percent of people who get covered are
likely to be hospitalized
when again the figures are nothing like
that uh
so you talk about the overreaction do
you think that western governments in
particular
overreacted to the pandemic well they
first under reacted and then overreacted
i think that would be the right way to
put
it but there was a way to get this right
that averted
mass death and also averted lockdowns it
was what they did in
taiwan the taiwanese who have every
reason to be suspicious of their
neighbors the people's republic of china
very quickly realized that something
wicked was coming their way from wuhan
restricted travel but more importantly
actually wrapped up testing
because it was quite easy to test for
this virus early on
sequencing the virus had proved to be
very very easy
they also had a system of integrated
contact tracing using
phones and so they were able to quickly
identify who had it and who
might have spread it and then to isolate
people who were infected and as a result
of this very rapid response 12 people
a dozen have died of cove in taiwan
which is right next door to where this
thing
began so we know there was a right way
of doing this the south koreans also did
very well
there were a bunch of countries that
were quick off the mark
and were therefore able to avert
lockdowns taiwan had the least stringent
government measures of any country
when you look at the oxford blavatnik
school stringency index
so that tells us that that what happened
in the uk in the us was clearly
sub-optimal
what happened was that the public health
officials dithered around and so did the
politicians but i think we should
recognize that
ultimately sounding the alarm about a
pandemic is not the job of the prime
minister it's the job of the people
who's whose job it is to worry about
public health
the public health officials dithered
around at both sides of the atlantic
january february first half of april
and then another neil ferguson i want to
make it clear that i'm not here
before the hate mail begins the neil
ferguson at imperial college london the
epidemiologist published
a paper mid-march saying if we don't
lock down
and he could have said like the chinese
who by that time had completely shut
everything down
if we don't log down we're going to have
half a million dead people in britain
and we're going to have 2.2 million dead
in the us
and politicians read this and thought oh
god
we better do this we better shut
everything down so there were
extraordinary measures taken uh from
mid-march onwards
like sheltering place orders here in
california locking people in their homes
because the initial opportunity to shut
the virus down had been missed
uh and then i think you can have a
debate about whether the lockdowns were
overkill and i think many respects
they were but what you can't i think say
is that we should have done nothing at
that point because by that point we
really had got ourselves into a serious
mess with
with the virus spreading rapidly all
across the u.s and all across
and all across europe we had to do
something i think we did more things
than we needed to
because those lockdowns were a very very
blunt instrument
and we also of course uh couldn't really
follow neil ferguson's
advice because he said you have to do
this until there are vaccines
now nobody in their right mind uh could
have
locked down uh the u.s or uk economy
for the entire period that it took to
get the vaccines available
uh and so what we did was we locked down
and then we realized we'd completely
created the economy and we had to start
lifting restrictions um and then play
whack-a-mole with re-infections
so looking back on it this was a pretty
big public policy failure to say that it
was going to be
a failure at the time was hard but i was
writing a weekly column back in those
days for the sunday times
and i do remember thinking that
ultimately we'd gone from
too little to too much and that that
that ensured we had lots of mortality
but also
huge economic and social disruption
definitely the worst of both worlds
and you say so it's the worst of both
worlds and when i was reading your book
you were talking about the relationship
that we have as a
as a society with death do you think
part of the problem with covert 19 was
we had a moral crisis
surrounding this virus i think part of
the reason for writing the book is is to
get people to think
a little bit more realistically about
death
there were moments in the discussion
last year when you'd have thought that
the job of politicians was to prevent
anybody from dying
now single death is too many hang on a
second people die every day that's
that's
the nature of our species only 13
of deaths since the pandemic began in
the united states being caused by code
i mean most people actually die of other
things once they get up
uh above age around 70. even in a
pandemic
excess mortality was certainly
significant probably
18 in the us and uk if you just look at
the whole period since this
thing began and that's a bad outcome i
mean
clearly it's a bad outcome for how over
half a million americans
to die and 120 130 000 brits to die but
relative to the population
in not talking about the black death
just to be clear in the black death
something around 40 of the population
of most european countries died the
global
shock of covert so far that the
percentage of the world's population
killed by this disease is about 0.04
percent
so the black death was three orders of
magnitude bigger than this and
if you take the 1980-19 influenza it was
a huge calamity something
in the region of 40 million people died
i mean for that number today
just adjusting for population you'd be
looking 160 million
deaths as opposed to what we're looking
at at the moment which is
three and we might well get to five or
maybe more by the time it's all over but
it's still not
it's not one of history's really big
pandemics so one of the things that's
striking i think is that
in the face of excess mortality we don't
have a good way of
of calibrating and that's because we
haven't got a good sense of what a bad
year looks like no
in britain there have been years
as bad as 2020 for excess mortality
uh but i'll tell you what they they've
been in in the recent past
1918 1940 and 1951
now your listeners will immediately get
1918
world war one plus the big spanish
influenza
1940 is a no-brainer uh obviously it's
it's world war ii and the catastrophic
first phase of the war
but what happened in 1951 1951 was as
bad a year as 2020 uh for excess
mortality
in the uk and that's because there was a
really bad outbreak of influenza
it wasn't global but it was very severe
in england especially around liverpool
for any
scousers listening we've forgotten it
it's completely forgotten
because people in the 1950s kind of
expected there to be
bad years they'd been through world war
ii uh there was a lot more still to come
there were many infectious diseases that
we hadn't got
under control polio for example uh and
so people
accepted that there was in the nature of
things
going to be the odd very bad winter and
by the way if you just look at
months of excess mortality yeah april
2020 was a very bad month in britain
but actually it's not even a top 10 bad
month
since 1970 and we got the data going
back
far so actually in my lifetime
there have been significantly worse
months for excess mortality
than the worst month of covert last year
part of the point of doom is just to
kind of
get that sense of perspective because
you have to you have to know whether
it's worth
shutting everything down uh in relation
to the the likely excess mortality that
you face because you don't want to
impose huge unintended costs in society
for the sake of a a bad winter
and in effect i think we may we may well
have done that we will never know
quite what the the death toll would have
been if we hadn't done lockdowns and so
neil ferguson's always going to say that
he saved
i don't know how many lives uh maybe uh
a quarter of a million or something like
that but
my sense is that that's probably not
right and that in truth
we could have got through this with
significantly less restriction on
people's
social and working lives and i'll never
be able to prove that nor will he be
able to prove that he saved them
that he saved england well the one thing
that we do know though neil don't we is
that
a lot of the the consequences of
lockdown which no one wants to talk
about have actually been resulted in
deaths as well
uh that's suicides that's cancer that's
miss heart people not going to
to accident an emergency to get
treatment for what then turns out to be
a heart attack
so yes maybe we'll never know but what
troubles me is not necessarily
what the numbers end up being but rather
the fact that we seem to have made a
decision
on lockdown without any regard for the
unintended consequences whatsoever no
one
people are pretending that that that
side of the formula just didn't exist
and obviously it did
yeah i mean it's clear that a lot of the
excess mortality uh
last year was not people dying of covert
there were a lot of other
things that that happened that would not
otherwise have happened we know for
example in the us that there's been a
big increase
in deaths from from overdose um and then
there are all the kind of
not so obvious costs i mean a year of
education has been taken away from
people in california public schools that
is to say
broadly speaking the poorer kids in
california society that will cost them
for the rest of their lives so i do
think you can
fairly say that the imperial college
epidemiologist said
here's what's going to happen if we
don't lock down and by the way
we're epidemiologists so don't bother us
with the
unintended consequences especially not
the economic ones because that's not
what we do but
here's here's a kind of way of saving
lives i think
those calculations were very very
crudely done
and they were based on a couple of
assumptions that were wrong
one the infection fatality rate which i
think they they got wrong because they
said it's going to be 0.9 percent if you
of the people who get it who die but
that actually was a bit
misleading because of the enormous
variance in
in the infection mortality by age 80
of people who died of covert in the u.s
are
65 and older and the older you get the
higher the rate so
it's essentially very unusual history to
have a pandemic that is ageist
most pandemics kill the very young the
very old
about the same amount and some actually
go after people in the prime of life
interestingly 1980-19 that
and 1957-58 increased mortality amongst
teenagers
in the united states by something like a
third so we had this kind of benign
pandemic that was generous enough to
leave young people alone
uh mostly and and concentrate on killing
people who were nearing
the end of their lives so under those
circumstances
and we knew that by the way in march
because the chinese data were already
there and you could see very clearly
that this was the aegis virus
knowing that we probably could have come
up with something smarter
than shutting everybody in their homes
and stopping them going to work
and i do remember long discussions with
uh with
people in different fields trying to
figure out what a smart
plan would look like because obviously a
smart plan would have protected the
elderly
and that was the one of the things we
didn't do because we left we let
huge numbers of people die in elderly
care homes
uh by not worrying about their
vulnerability and actually shipping
people with the virus to
elderly care homes making sure that very
large numbers of people there were were
affected so these these are the little
mistakes that
they end up having really really large
costs
now remember my key point is that we
should have been taiwan
by the time we got to mid-march we'd
already kind of blown it
but i think having blown it we could
still have been smarter than we were
in the way that we tried to to deal with
the pandemic and i i sense that the
costs when we finally do
a proper cost-benefit analysis the cost
of lockdown will turn out to be
much higher than people thought at the
beginning
and you say that and i i'm in an
agreement with you
has it surprised you neil how we seem to
have politicized this virus
you know both sides have done it it's a
bit it's been really shocking to me and
by the way just to add it didn't happen
straight away there was about a month
somewhere around february march when
it hadn't quite broken either way and
people on both sides of the normal
political divide
were not sort of there wasn't the same
alignment whereas now it's very clear if
you're on the left you're pro lock down
on your right you're probably not um
yeah so talk to us about the
politicization of this
it's one of the striking differences
between
our time and the 1950s uh especially in
the us because if you think it's
politicized in britain
you ain't seen nothing here every aspect
of this public health crisis became
politicized uh
mask wearing potential remedies for the
disease
and then of course the vaccine and
vaccine resistance is much more stubborn
in the us than it is in the uk i.e
resistance to getting
the vaccine so what went wrong back in
the 1950s
it really wasn't controversial that
getting a vaccine for a contagious virus
would be good so when the asian flu as
it was then called
struck the federal government in the u.s
prioritized getting a vaccine and that
was really
all they did because they recognized
that they couldn't shut everything down
so schools stayed open
workplaces stayed open yeah there was
excess mortality
but they got the vaccine done really
quickly within a matter of a few months
from developing a vaccine to getting
into people's arms
faster in other words than than we've
done and it wasn't controversial
nobody was saying that it was a
republican uh
vaccine because eisenhower was president
here i think you can see he
illustrated a theme of my last book the
last book the square in the tower said
the way that the internet has evolved as
our new public sphere
has exacerbated polarization
because on the internet you were
incentivized
to have extreme views to disseminate
fake news
because the internet platforms the
facebooks and the googles
are incentivized by their business model
to
basically promote clickbait that's how
you get eyeballs to stay on the screen
long enough to see ads it wasn't like
that in the 1950s
there's a finite amount of terrestrial
television there's radio there's local
papers
the the window the spectrum of of
information in news is much more limited
and the crazy stuff really doesn't get
much beyond
men with green ink writing letters the
internet's created this entirely
different
news system where news and entertainment
have kind of fused
and the incentive is always to go out on
the extreme
to try to get those eyeballs to linger
just a bit longer on the screen
so you're right at the beginning
constantine is very true
uh at the beginning uh it was actually
liberal media who
condemned trump for wanting to restrict
travel from china
it was in the new york times in the
washington post that they ran articles
saying
it's just the seasonal flu the
president's a terrible racist for
wanting to do this
and it took a while for that all to flip
it really took until
march for the position to become
liberals like lockdowns and and
conservatives like herd immunity
so this was absurd it led to absurd
debates
and the public health officials made
matters worse by
changing their story on masks for
reasons that were transparently
transparently mendacious oh you don't
need a mask because we actually don't
have enough
and we need them for the doctors and
then actually change a plan
you need to wear two make it three can
you blame people for becoming skeptical
about the utterances
of people like anthony fauci so we've
ended up in a terribly
i think a sub-optimal situation in which
uh the public is skeptical about uh
official guidance
it goes to the internet in search of uh
better guidance and it
ends up down conspiracy theory wormholes
that tell you the vaccine is
bill gates's plan for total mind control
i mean the number of people who believe
that stuff
is truly shocking i knew that americans
had a weakness for conspiracy theories
already i wrote about it in the square
in the tower
well the pandemic was just a glorious
opportunity for the conspiracy theory
networks to go crazy and uh and sure
enough that's why
there's so much reluctance to get the
vaccine especially amongst the
amongst conservatives do you have a
website or do you plan to have a website
well if you do then easy dns are the
company for you
easy dns is the perfect domain name
registrar provider and web host for you
they have a track record of standing up
for their clients
whether it be council culture d platform
attacks
or overzealous government agencies he
knows a bit about that
so will you in a second easy dns have
rock solid
network infrastructure and incredible
customer support
they're in your corner no matter what
the world throws at you
unless it's your ex-girlfriend in which
case you're on your own you'd know about
that
move your domains and websites over to
easy dns
right now all you've got to do is head
over to easydns.com
forward slash triggered and use our
promo code
which is of course triggered as well and
you will get 50
off of the initial purchase sign up for
the newsletter
access of easy that tells you everything
you need to know
about technology privacy and censorship
neil do you think part of the problem is
and
it's going to sound flippant is that
we've all been driven insane
you know we've been locked in our houses
we've
you know our you know our our movements
have been curtailed and the ability to
see family
hooked up to social media for 24 hours a
day
it's driven us all mad hasn't it well
it's not a frivolous point
francis because actually mental health
has become
its own pandemic you are doing things to
people
that are calculated to put them under
psychological strain and that the data
on mental illness are really shocking
it's become
far far more of a problem uh than it was
before
not surprisingly as you rightly say if
you if you lock people up in their homes
they are unfortunately deprived of
things that are good for sanity
we are a social species we're not really
designed to just be
stuck in cells uh with a very small
number of people that's why prison
is punishment but if you place the
entire population under house arrest
unless you're somebody with a large and
spacious home with a decent garden
um it's really rather stressful uh and i
i do think that this is
is one of those those costs that will
only gradually become
obvious but i mean we already have
pretty good evidence that this has been
a huge
psychological strain on societies and
and i you know spent much of the
pandemic in a in a pretty relaxed place
montana uh listening to my kids and my
mother talked about life
in england uh which i had to do over a
zoo made me realize that
things really were much more restricted
in the uk
so yeah i think i think this is a very
important point
and it means that we we have to
acknowledge that there were at least two
pandemics going on simultaneously why
was the virus
the other was let me call it the sort of
pandemic of the mind
and this pandemic of the mind range from
people who are pretty well adjusted in
relatively com
comfortable circumstances feeling
miserable
to people in much more difficult
circumstances with perhaps already some
mental strain
thing really mentally ill and that
second pandemic
will have all kinds of lasting
consequences of course it made people
susceptible
to crazy ideas if you're already under
some stress
and somebody tells you here did you know
that this is actually a pandemic
devised to put microchips into your
bloodstream
under the circumstances of 2020 a
surprisingly large number of people
will believe that now rewind to the
1340s
biggest probably the biggest pandemic in
all of history the black death
sure enough what we find in the 1340s is
not only that there's mass
death but there are also crazy ideas
that spread
amazingly fast uh for example
the flagellate orders are founded and
people wander around
men exclusively wander around whipping
themselves to try to ward off
uh the knicks contagion i was fascinated
when i read about
the flagellates many years ago in norman
cohen's great book the pursuit of the
millennium because
there was a certain amount of that kind
of mood
in the united states in in 2020 the
black lives matter protests ostensibly
were about police brutality
but if you looked at it with the
detachment of the historian it looked a
lot like
the flagellate orders processing through
european cities in the 1340s
in an act of expiation you know if we
can only
uh punish ourselves for the racism of
the past
somehow will ward off divine wrath there
was something of that about 2020
so there was a pandemic of the mind in
our time just as
had been in in the middle ages i did
tweet recently that the only thing that
surprises me about this pandemic is no
one has decided to blame the jews yet
um but give it time
because you're quite right that in the
1340s there were terrible outbreaks of
anti-semitic violence in in multiple
european cities and
and these events are very shocking
jewish communities in some
german cities were kind of burnt to
death or there was mass murder
in some other form now what's
interesting is that
one manifestation of the plague of the
mind uh
what what what we call woken for short
all that complex of of radical left
ideas that
that seems to flourish in american
academia these days
i mean that has its anti-semitic side to
it there's no question so
i think the connection that you've just
suggested
jokingly is kind of already being made
i'm afraid
great news but neil let's uh let's move
on a little bit i want to talk about
china uh and the reason i want to talk
about it is
can you as a historian first of all just
very briefly
i'll lock down something that we've
inherited from the past in other words
this is something that people have done
prior or is it the chinese came up with
it
and now everyone's doing it there's
never been anything like this
in in the great influenza pandemics of
the 20th century nobody thought about
shutting everybody up in their homes it
wasn't an option because you couldn't
work from home in 1957 and nor in 1918
that that just wasn't an option for most
people whereas now something like a
third of jobs in the us
can be done at home that's because the
internet has made
basically yeah sorry to interrupt so
what we've done
and just uh i'm a layman in this but
what we've done is we've taken
the response of an authoritarian
communist dictatorship halfway around
the world
and imported it into western liberal
democracy
entirely yeah we didn't weld people into
their apartments but we might as well
have done
with with no with no precedent for this
whatsoever
yeah but they've got good food so well
neil ferguson the other neil ferguson
admitted this
in an interview at the time the other
day i mean he said the the chinese kind
of gave us permission to do this and we
weren't sure that we could do it not
being a communist
regime and it turned out that we could
that's the really remarkable thing
about what happened last year i think
it's
right to say that we copied the chinese
model
because if you look back at the the
debates of
of march 2020 there weren't really many
examples of lockdowns
to to go on all you could see was that
things were going
horribly wrong in north italy it was a
terror
that the same thing was going to happen
in england
and there was a chinese model for
repressing the virus
that was getting a lot of publicity
because the chinese were rather proud of
the fact that they'd been able to impose
such draconian restrictions
on their people now it's actually
impossible for us to replicate what
chinese did because the chinese
communist party has an active
member in every apartment block in every
chinese city
whose job it is to report on on his or
her neighbors
and that we don't yet have certainly
have lots of nosy parkers
that's that's part of english life since
i'm a memorial but they're not members
of the communist party
and they don't report to big brother so
what about coven marshalls
well of course we have a certain
tradition in british
life of of restricting freedom in an
emergency which
we go it goes back to world war ii and
so yeah if we can all remember
uh even if it's only from watching dad's
army that there was a certain kind of
person who quite enjoyed enforcing
the blackout regulations and those same
people or their grandchildren suddenly
had a wonderful opportunity to be
busy bodies about uh about covert
but i think you're right to identify
that we basically
copied the chinese lockdown model but
that was the wrong
china to copy the right china was the
republic of china
taiwan which had done the winning
combination of
of mass testing very early on contact
tracing
and isolation of the infected but the
taiwanese were basically ignored by the
world health organization
because it's so much enthralled to
beijing and so nobody paid much
attention to what the taiwanese were
doing it was actually brilliant and it
worked really really well
so we copied the wrong china
unfortunately let me just follow up on
this francis so
if this is what we've done and i i i
care passionately about civil liberties
i come from the soviet union where we
had very few of them
i know how precious they are and what
happens when
uh they're not protected by society
from a as a historian what is the impact
of adopting wholesale an authoritarian
methodology
into a liberal society because it
strikes me that in the context of
of china this may not have even been
seen particularly by the people as
as something vastly different from their
day-to-day lives
but in the west this is unprecedented
and
it worries me that we may have broken
something the contract that the public
have with government
may be affected for a very long time by
this what do you think about
that hugely important question at the
end of the book
i say the biggest danger that we face
is not actually climate change i take
that seriously but it's not the biggest
danger
biggest danger that we face is
totalitarianism because totalitarianism
was responsible for more avoidable death
in the 20th century than anything else
the totalitarian regimes killed their
own people and they killed other people
and they did it on a massive scale
whether you're talking about stalin
hitler or mao those regimes
were responsible for an insane amount
of avoidable death unfortunately we did
not
kill off totalitarianism at the end of
the first cold war
because it survived to fight another day
in china and not only did it survive but
it then
flourished has gone from strength to
strength
by exploiting uh the benefits of the
market economy without sacrificing
dominance of the one party state and
unfortunately copying china is
uh a way of importing into free
societies
uh the kind of software of of the unfree
society i
dread uh to see any more articles
of the form we should learn from china
it's going to be the chinese century
look how smart they are because that
just an invitation
to to import totalitarian ways of doing
things
yes in the past in time of emergency
we have restricted civil liberties we
did it in both world wars
in quite drastically actually but
everybody understood
uh in the world wars that it was a
temporary state of emergency that would
be
ended as soon as the war was over the
problem with doing it in a pandemic
is that it's quite easy to argue that in
fact it's never going to be over
because the virus will always be out
there and then
this is one of the typically
totalitarian sounding slogans you hear
there's no no safety it's not over until
it's until there are no cases at all
anywhere in the world
now if you make that argument you will
be able to justify covert restrictions
forever and i do think this has been an
opportunity
for a power grab by state bureaucracies
even in countries and nominally under
conservative leadership
in the u.s it's very obvious in the us
democratic party
uh at the state level seized the
opportunity
to expand its control over citizens
california
is a strange place it's a one-party
state oddly enough here
and the californian democrats really do
quite like locking people up in their
homes
they seem to enjoy it rather as i think
the scottish national party
uh do and this is a very disturbing
tendency to me because it suggests
that it's possible to have totalitarian
behavior
without a big brother-like dictatorship
because there are people who actually
enjoy it
if that's the case there are two ways in
which we're threatened by
totalitarianism one
if china becomes the world power if
china becomes dominant
we're threatened by it but were also
threatened by totalitarianism from
within because they do seem to be people
who quite enjoy informing on their
neighbors or their colleagues
and there do seem to be bureaucrats for
whom there's no greater pleasure than to
impose new restrictions on individual
liberty
and does that surprise you neil that
there's some people who grew up in the
you know the tolerant liberal west
who've got a real thirst for
authoritarianism
i wish i could say that i'd seen this
coming
and it doesn't surprise me because
obviously we we love to be
precedent but i did not anticipate
particularly when i went into academic
life back in the 1980s
that universities would become the
places where free speech was most
limited in in our societies that i did
not see coming and i
didn't see it coming even even ten years
ago so i
i think one of the things i've learned
in the last few years really i think it
began to dawn on me in about 2016
is that you can have totalitarianism
from the grassroots up
it's not necessary to have a
a stalin for people to start to engage
in the behavior we associate with stalin
soviet union
that that culture where you inform on
people uh
and officials then use uh non-due
process
to to cancel people cancellation is
a little like being purged uh in the
soviet union
the more i think about it the more it
seems to me there are totalitarian
behaviors
which kind of originated in academic
life that are spreading outwards into
the rest of society
you know there's there are aspects of of
university life that one sees
which are very reminiscent of the
cultural revolution in china where
professors are sort of accused by their
students and have to
humiliate themselves with apologies and
then struggled with
uh and then purged cancelled from the
internet all of this is going on without
there being
big brother and that i don't think i
would have predicted
even as recently as the 2015.
and neil since you bring it up it's
slightly aside from the subject of your
book but we'd be remiss
not to ask you about this um depending
on who you talk to we recently had uh
mary abbastad on the show who talked
about
identity politics stemming from the
sexual revolution
the breakdown of the family the
breakdown of community
you get you get you get atomized
individuals as a result people look for
belonging
and they look to their identity uh other
people would argue it's the long march
to the institutions the
the neo-marxist inve invade and
infiltrate the university and education
system and
indoctrinate young people with that
where does this woke culture come from
in your opinion as a historian
i think there's some truth in both those
hypotheses but i'm i'm strongly
attracted to
a phrase that uh a left wing but
left liberal writer came up with this
mattie iglesias's great awokening
wokism has a religious quality to it and
in some ways it's part of a long
american tradition of periodic religious
revivals when the country's puritan
roots
manifest themselves and there is a sort
of part of
of american culture that does yearn
uh to ostracize people if not to
actually burn
witches and i one of the ironies of all
of this
is that what margaret app would
envisaged
in the handmaid's tale which was a kind
of
right-wing dystopia
has actually happened or begun to happen
on the left instead
and i i think that's that's really the
crux of the matter that this has a
quasi-religious quality to it and
and one of the signs of this is that
the the belief system that involves
various
strange uses of language and strange
rituals
that are designed really to to to
separate
the the elect the true believers in
wokism
from everybody else now you said this
was a little bit of a
sideline but it's not actually if if
you're talking about the history of
disaster as doom does
it's clear that one of the most
disastrous periods
uh in modern history uh was in fact in
the 17th century when
uh the 30 years war happened and the 30
years war was a kind of culmination
of about 130 years of of deep religious
division
uh beginning with with martin luther's
reformation
and that there's a sense in which we're
kind of in that
world today even if it's not religion
so much as the secular religions of
politics that are really being
fought over but we've left behind that
uh that
period that i feel i belong to the
period which you could
have free speech and you debated uh and
you debated
uh pretty aggressively but there was a
sort of
argument plus evidence approach to
resolving differences
when you go back to the 17th century
that's not possible because
you just say that the other side are
heretics and what do you do with
heretics
you burn them so we are in the kind of
much more
religious moments than we perhaps
realize because
we assume that we're talking about
politics but actually the way people
talk about politics
in an american university is much more
like the way they talked about religion
in the 17th century
and doesn't it also give give voice to
the lie that we tell ourselves that we
live in a post-religious society
we don't need religion we have science
but this embrace of wokism
shows us that we actually do we need
a belief system in order to adhere to it
to give us meaning
it is not the case sadly that gk
chesterton said
the trouble with atheism is not that men
believe in nothing it's that they
believe in anything he didn't actually
say that
that's one of these quotes attributed to
him that nobody can quite
claim uh to author but it's a very good
insight
and and chesterton thought something
along these lines
post-christian europe and increasingly
post-christian america
sadly for richard dawkins and other
militant atheists
is not a place where the principles of
the enlightenment are
universally embraced uh
quite the opposite um in fact these
these post-christian
uh societies seem to be amenable to all
kinds of
uh wild superstitious belief we talked a
little bit about
conspiracy theories before but it's sort
of broader than that
and people who think that they're
invoking
the science and this is a dreadful uh
term actually because there is no such
thing as
the science are very often in fact
enthralled to some
uh legacy religious belief of course the
best example is clearly
uh the millenarianism the belief in the
imminent end of the world which has
found a new home
in radical environmentalism so it's
impossible not to see as an historian
that
the the religious undertone of much that
someone like greta tunberg
says and indeed at times she seems like
some child
saint from the middle ages sent to warn
of the impending
apocalypse so yeah i think one of the
other things that the pandemic revealed
was that the people who talk
most about the science are in fact
anything but scientific in in their
approach
are in fact i i think enthralled to some
version of
of religion without even being aware of
it
where do we go from here now because you
invoke the example of the 30-year war as
you say
the culmination of a longer religious
struggle
you make the parallel with our modern
society now
where are we going one of the
conclusions of the book is that we
nearly always
are well prepared for the wrong disaster
and one can sense that
enormous efforts are going to go in over
the next
10 years to discussing climate change
again which was what we were doing back
in january 2020 when a pandemic was
actually beginning
i think we've decided that that's going
to be our disaster
and we're going to spend a lot of time
and energy
preparing for it and history warns us
that you don't get the disaster that you
prepare for
so where do we go from here i think the
biggest
nearest most likely danger is
some kind of major conflict and it can
take a number of different forms but i'd
put my money on a u.s china conflict
because all the ingredients are there
now
for a superpower showdown which nobody
will quite
intend to escalate but which will
nevertheless do so
i think that that's a disaster we're not
giving nearly enough thought to
partly because we've got used to wars
being small things that don't really
affect us directly
we've forgotten what a really big war
looks like but i worry about
what would happen if there were an
escalation over let's say taiwan
and we had full-blown cyber warfare now
what we don't know
is just how much uh the other side could
disrupt
our our own critical infrastructure but
my guess is
way more than we assume and the worry is
that in the case of a u.s china conflict
there would be really significant
disruption of
our our internet capabilities
and there would also be a massive uh
dissemination of disinformation and
misinformation because the russians
already know how to do that well and the
chinese are getting better at
i think in the short run while we're
having uh our conferences about climate
change which is a relatively slow moving
problem
there is a near-term and very disruptive
scenario of conflict with china
and that's why i said earlier that
totalitarianism is really the big
the big worry because this is a very
very well armed totalitarian regime now
and it's
much richer than the soviet union ever
was much closer to us in terms of gross
domestic product
so you ask what's next i think that's
the kind of crisis that is pretty
imminent
of course it might not escalate the
biden administration might just
fold if the choices between fighting for
taiwan or not fighting and they may just
decide that the midterms are more
important but that would be a
major seismic shift in the geopolitical
order and china would really
at that point have become the dominant
global power as surely as the u.s was
after the suez crisis
so i worry a bit about an american
crisis over taiwan
that wouldn't necessarily lead to
enormous numbers of deaths but i think
the loss of american dominance
would have all kinds of unforeseeable
consequences if the winner was china
and neil understandably
this interview has been i wouldn't say
doom and gloom but
let's let's say uh a you know
pessimistic appraisal of what's been
happening
but look they have when there's
pandemics there's always
things that happen afterwards positives
that happen
are there any particular positives that
you could look
to see looking back at history that
could come out of this pandemic i'd love
if you just said no
well it's a bit like a joke isn't it a
russian and englishman and the scotsman
went into a
into a chat room and and of course the
scotsman is going to be like
private fraser from dad's army or doomed
part of the point of calling the book
doom was to make a bit of
fun of myself and of world history
because really
the major point of the book is we're not
doomed the end of the world has been
predicted countless times and
it has not happened and even the worst
disasters don't kill everyone
even the black death couldn't even get
to half of humanity
it probably managed about a third at
most so
we survive we're remarkably resilient
even
despite our own stability and when we
come out of a disaster as we
we will come out of this disaster we're
coming out of it now i mean look
look at the uk deaths are in the low
double digits pretty
pretty soon we'll be in the single
digits and after as you come up with
disaster
you do have the right to have a most
terrific party and this is something
that i think
uh has already kind of begun you can
feel it happening
it's going to be the most uh
tremendously enjoyable
summer as long as it doesn't rain the
whole time in england and
and that that will extend i think until
really the the autumn
and if we're lucky and there isn't some
kind of recurrence
of the the pandemic in the winter we're
going to feel
really quite cheerful because we're
going to get back all that was taken
away from us
including above all else that the
opportunity to be
gregarious won't it feel great when we
can actually go to the footy
and sing again because singing and
hurling abuse
the other team's fans are great sources
of pleasure
in british life that we've been deprived
of i hate
football without fans it is a deeply
unmoving spectacle even although i
dutifully watch
so there's a lot that's going to feel
great just in the same way as when you
stop beating your hair get
head against a brick wall it's really
it's quite a relief the question is how
long will it last
i mean my friend nicholas christakis
talked about the roaring 20s coming back
and i think that's wishful thinking
because i think the economy will roar
for the second half of
of 2021 and then we'll start realizing
that it's actually a little trickier
than it looks to come back from a
pandemic but yeah
and i'm definitely going to have a very
very fun summer
seeing my kids and my mom and my friends
whom i haven't seen for a year and a
half
and i think this is the thing to the
this is the note to end on i mean the
great thing about doom
is you worry about it a lot sometimes
you kind of read about it almost for
pleasure
but then you survive and there's a kind
of spring in your step thinking ah i was
one of the lucky ones
well there you go uh most of you are
gonna die but some of you will be fine
and that is the message of this
interview
uh neil all of us are going to die a pop
maybe from peter
but it's just a question of when and
ideally not not today
not today um neil thank you so much
we're going to ask you a couple of
questions for locals but before we do
uh we have our uh usual last question
for you
which is what's the one thing we're not
talking about but we really should be
i learned in writing doom that there
have been periods in
in history in which volcanic activity
has had a huge impact on human life
the late 1100s to the late 1200s there
was a time of extraordinary global
cooling because of huge numbers of
volcanoes going off
and we haven't had a big volcanic
eruption since 1815
so you know 200 plus years ago which was
uh
mount tambora so i'm kind of every time
i see a volcano story in the papers i
sort of sit up wondering if it's going
to be a real big one but
yeah that that's something we don't
think nearly enough about but but i
spent the pandemic right next to
the yellowstone super volcano location
if if that thing went off
which it hasn't done for a very very
long time then i mean you'd have to
cancel the conferences on
on global warming because that would no
longer be the problem
excellent you can look forward to the
earth exploding as well uh fantastic
stuff
well uh neil thank you so much for
coming on the book is called doom
uh thoroughly recommend it and thank you
all for watching
we will see you very soon with another
brilliant interview like this one
or all show all of them go out at 7pm uk
time take care and see you soon guys
we hope you've enjoyed this incredible
interview remember to subscribe
and hit the bell button so that you
never miss another fantastic episode
and if you believe that the work we do
here at trigonometry is important
support us by joining our locals
community using the link below